hallo eigentlich wollte ich erst morgen
ein video für euch drehen und zwar habe
ich morgen ein rezept video für euch
aber aus gegebenem anlass musste ich
jetzt schon ein video für euch machen
und zwar könnt ihr euch denken was geht
es geht um einen job den ich gestern
abend um 18 uhr eröffnet habe und ich
muss sagen also ich bereit mich wirklich
erstmal veralten die beiden stellt haben
der shop läuft so gut dass eigentlich
die produkte schon fast wieder alle auf
ausverkauft sind und ich am montag
gleich wieder die nächste große
bestellung machen muss und ich möchte
mich da wirklich bei jedem einzelnen
erst mal bedanken für des vertrauten was
er mir entgegenbringt und einfach auch
für die unterstützung weil ohne diese
ganze youtube geschichte ist eigentlich
nicht so weit gekommen wäre und es war
einfach schon immer mein traum ich in
diesen bereichen mit meinem hobby zu
verwirklichen und das habt ihr mir jetzt
praktisch ermöglicht jetzt habe ich aber
auch viele e mails erreicht gestern
abend heute morgen eigentlich die ganze
nacht einfach über einzelne produkte
auch und über meine job amsterdam
anschaut muss ich euch sagen der ist
jetzt echt innerhalb kürzester zeit
entstanden der notiz aufgebaut wir haben
tage und nächte damit verbracht diesen
shop so aufzustellen wir jetzt ist und
ich muss sagen also meine erwartungen
trifft nicht
meine erwartung hat auch nicht erfüllt
weil er einfach optisch noch nicht
meinen wünschen entspricht
und ich habe da jetzt echt auch damit zu
kämpfen ob ich ihn überhaupt
veröffentlichen soll aber mir geht es
einfach darum ihr wartet jetzt alle
schon auf die produkte und im endeffekt
zählen jetzt erstmal nur die produkte
und die qualität der produkte und meinen
job werde ich jetzt noch mit der zeit
optimieren und da wirklich drauf schaut
das ist einfach mein job ist und alles
nach meinen wünschen läuft es kamen seit
gestern abend wirklich sehr viele
bestellungen ein
ich glaube so um die 600 c 112 bisschen
und es kamen aber auch sehr viele fragen
zu den inhaltsstoffen oder zu den
produkten selbst was mich ganz wichtig
hier zu den inhaltsstoffen ich wurde oft
gefragt ob die produkte gelatine
enthalten und da kann ich sagen dass die
farben und erfolg drin und so weiter die
internen alle keine gelatine
das ist alles auf pflanzlicher basis
oder eben mit anderen mitteln
aber gerade in fertigem von landwirt
eigentlich nie gelatine benutzt deswegen
nehme ich dann ganz gerne
gelatine könnt ihr an der enova auch
feststellen wenn es steht nicht immer
dran in den in den zutaten dass das hat
ihnen ist sondern das ist auch die
nummer 141 und es ist in meinem produkt
nicht enthalten
weder in den farben noch in den von
damit massen
also es sind gerade die farben und die
fundsachen auch für vegetarier aber eben
auch für muslime geeignet und wenn es
beim bereich relativ bleiben
in meinem shop kids auch die hallesche
lassen
die habe ich jetzt direkt vom hersteller
und die könnt ihr eben jetzt hier auch
bekommen
das ist eine reine rinder gelatine und
die könnt ihr ganz normal verwenden wie
jede normale andere gelatine eben auch
und wenn ich jetzt gerade bei den von
den zutaten will ja vielleicht gesehen
dass es noch keinen 10c und noch keinen
blitzer ringen gibt und zwar ist er
einfach das problem was ich da
eigentlich keine amerikanischen produkte
nehmen möchte und die auch vom deutschen
hersteller haben möchte und da haben wir
jetzt im moment noch eine schwierigkeit
jemanden zu finden der mir das eben auch
liefern kann und es wird dann natürlich
auch in zukunft geben
aber da ich einfach nochmal darüber und
jetzt möchte ich euch ein bisschen was
zu meinen starterset sagen
und zwar habe ich für euch zwei starter
sets zusammengestellt einmal ein bug
starterset und einmal ein
online startet und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal ein backstein und zwar sind
es alles produkte von steht das ist mein
hauptlieferant weil ich einfach die
produkte von später richtig klasse
findet und in diesem bug starterset
sieht jetzt so aus
ihr habt einen verstellbaren tortenring
den könnt ihr einstellen von 18
zentimeter bis auf 30 und könnte auch
hier am rand schön sehen die
einstellungen das ist er agiert könnte
praktisch den ring einstellen und jetzt
hätte ich zum beispiel 24 zentimeter
durchmesser form und kann es eben nach
belieben einstellen die vorhandene höhe
von zehn zentimetern
also das ist das erste was dabei ist das
zweite ist der ecke gebracht haben
das sieht so aus ist sieben zentimeter
mehr und stehen kann man eben je nach
größe einstellen
so wie ich das eben euch bisher auch
immer gezeigt habe ihr wisst ja dass ich
immer die produkte von lara hatte und
ich bin auch sehr begeistert vorgemacht
alles keine frage die kurze wirklich
klasse allerdings haben wir auch einen
stolzen preis
und ich habe deswegen eben nach dem
hersteller gesucht der genauso eine gute
qualität hat aber einfach preis nicht
etwas besser lebt und deswegen habe ich
erzählt die städter produkte das sind
auch alles edelstahl formen und alles
edelstahlwerk rahmen und die haben eine
etwas anderes system
aber ich bin die preis leistung stimmt
hier einfach die produkte sind klasse
und die zeitlich einfach noch was noch
in dem set enthalten ist und zwar gibt
es hier auch diese dauer portfolien die
ich verwende allerdings sind diese
schwarz das hat den einfachen vorteil
dass schwarz im backofen einfach
schneller heiß wird durch diese
reflektion von dem licht und heute
erklären und dadurch habt ihr sogar mit
kürzerer zeit als mit normalen braunem
packpapier und was hier eben noch ganz
wichtig ist ist dieses backblech mit
dieser speziellen und zwar stellt ihr
dieses backblech einmal auf euren
backofen all das geht ganz einfach über
diese leiste hier
diese leiste da außen ist verstellbar
und dann nehme ich mir einen neuen
spitzen gegenstand und drückt hier ein
mädchen im stift zum beispiel kann man
mein blech einstellen
das auseinanderziehen zusammendrücken
und dann habe ich auf meine backblech
größe eingestellt dann kommt hier in
bauerbach folie drauf und dann eben mein
tortenring oder mein anderer torben
brandt und es ist auch ganz wichtig dass
ihr die trocken renner wenn es sie zum
backen verwendet
mit diesem backblech benutzt weil wenn
ihr das auch ein ganz normales mark
frost stellt oder auf ein backblech was
vielleicht so eine kleine wölbung rinnen
hat dann läuft euch einfach der teig
komplett nach außen aus und dann erzählt
ihr eben nicht das ergebnis gewünscht
habt deswegen ganz wichtig diese
backwaren immer auf dieses spezial bad
nicht stellen
und dann
habe ich hier noch diese zwei dinge und
zwar zwei kuchen retter mit denen hier
kann man einfach den kuchen schön
anheben oder auch drauf verlieren
also ich finde die immer optimal
einmalig einmal lohnt und der eckige
toppen retter haben eine größe von 43
auf 32 zentimetern und dieser runde
torquato hatten durchmesser von 32
zentimetern und alles was ihr hier seht
debug rahmen und die unterlagen sind
alle aus edelstahl das heißt rostfrei
und wirklich formstabil und es ist
ebenso dieses wrack status etwas ich
einfach für euch zusammengestellt habe
weil es einfach die wichtigsten
komponenten enthält er einen eckigen und
runden back rahmen und eckigen und und
torten retter und so zum einstieg aber
auch ebenso zum darauf aufbaut ist
wirklich ein ganz tolles und jetzt zeige
ich euch noch mein zweites standorts
weiß dass das ganze starterfeld und dass
er einfach alle dinge enthalten die ihr
braucht wenn ihr mich verstanden volt
und dann zeige ich euch einfach mal was
da mit dabei ist und zwar habt ihr hier
erst mal 200 gramm becker stellte sich
jetzt leider schon aufgebrochen der
packung überhaupt das ganze zeit schon
aufgebrochen ohne dass euch weise zeigen
dass sich die bäcker steigt und die ich
mir dann in meinen steuer gefüllt hatte
deswegen aber das ist eine volle
komplette 200 gramm packung tiere
bekommt sagt einen kletter und zwar
diesen von deutlich leichter mit dem ihr
die oberseite der torte schön kämpfen
könnt ihr habt darin enthalten ein call
verdammt gutes denn ich jetzt noch habt
das habt es leider auch schon
aufgebrochen nicht vergessen euch falls
es wieder zu drehen
aber egal er bekommt ein komplettes
genom rolf vom dampf und dann bekommt
ihr drei passen farben und zwar indem
standard in den grundtönen und zwar
gelb-rot und tschechiens also türkis
eben als blau das blaue wird es eben
eingesetzt und die zutaten und die
werkzeuge alles von der firma städte
dazu sage ich jetzt gleich noch was
hier habt ihr vier blumen ausstecher
noch mit dabei bin ich ganz süß weil es
einfach so diese standard blumen sind
mit ausstecher mitaussteller funktion
eben und mit dieser auswärts funktion
und die gleichzeitig eben hin damit noch
ein kleines loch rein prägt das essen
locken und vertiefen
dadurch werden die blumen etwas
plastischer dann habt ihr mich dabei das
motto werkzeug das fünfteilige das finde
ich echt super draht für den preis ich
arbeite gerne damit
und ihr habt noch eine kurve fahren mit
dabei und zwar eine kristallkugel farbe
in der farbe weiß und mit dieser farbe
könnt ihr eure oberfläche also eure von
oberflächen sondern schönen schimmer
verleiht
wie gesagt sind alle produkte hier in
diesem starterfeld auch meine farben
mein fondant in meinem job alles von der
firma steht
ich war bei steht direkt bei der
produktion mit dabei ich habe gesehen
wie die wut auf die
herstellungsbedingungen sind ich habe
gesehen wie die produkte gemacht werden
ich hab die mitarbeiter kennen gelernt
ich habe einfach einen einblick gekriegt
es kommt in die komplette firma und ich
war begeistert davon und mehr habt
deswegen mich dazu entschlossen diese
produkte in meinem shop anzubieten und
steht da ist einmal der hauptlieferanten
und wer ist einfach wichtig dass ich
auch mal bei der produkte mit dabei sein
kann dass ich weiß welche produkte ich
verkaufe und eben welche produkte für
mich wichtig sind und diese habe ich
eben
in meinem shop mit aufgenommen und nach
und nach werden da immer mehr produkte
kommen aber eben deswegen machen mache
weil ich alle produkte vorher testen
muss wie es zählt alles schon gebrochen
und so und deswegen kommt es jetzt alles
wieder zeit und der shop peter neben
erweitert und ich wurde gestern und
heute schon angeschrieben dass die
speisen passten farben also die
lebensmittel fahren etwas teurer sind
als in anderen shops deshalb einfach den
einfachen grund dass ich eben diesen
deutschen hersteller nehme der
produziert in deutschland seine waren
und ich weiß einfach was drinsteckt glas
sind hier auch abfallstoffe drin wie bei
minden
aber es ist eben nicht so wie beim alten
bei wilden ist es nämlich so dass die
eben mehr ans ufer stoffe drin haben und
die städter farben enthalten die zwar
auch aber eben nur in ganz geringer
konzentration eben nur so viel wie bei
uns in deutschland eben zum glück dann
auch zugelassen ist und ich lege wert
darauf was ich esse was meine tochter
ist und was meine familie und meine
freunde essen
ich lege auch bald darauf was ich den
supermarkt einkaufen und deswegen lege
ich wert auf qualität und was ich eben
schon im letzten angesagt habe in einem
video sind die städte haben einfach sehr
ergiebig diesen haltbar bis 2018 wir
haben es 2013
das heißt sie halten fünf jahre fünf
jahre was davon
und wenn ihr das dann auf ein jahr unter
rechnet und euch ausrechnet was dann die
farbe pro jahr kostet dann hat sich das
eigentlich schon wieder relativiert und
so kann man das eben mit den anderen
vergleichen ohne ich möchte ich jetzt
einfach mal ein beispiel sein was ich
mit qualität und so weiter meine als ich
vor ein paar wochen fast quasi verkündet
habe dass ihn ein shop eröffnet
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
viele pakete dabei mir daheim
eingetroffen sind ich würde praktisch
überflutet mit paketen und anfragen und
sally verkauft dies der liefer kauft das
gemeine produktelinien du meine produkte
und ich zeige mich jetzt einfach mal so
ein beispiel als ich möchte damit jetzt
echt keinen schlecht reden oder
irgendjemand und persönlich angreifen
oder irgendwas ich möchte einfach mal
was mich die letzten wochen daheim
erwartet habe und was ich eben an
produkten dann ausgepackt habe und es
ist einfach nur ein paar beispiele
das meiste habe ich einfach wieder
zurückgeschickt wegschmeißen wollte ist
nämlich einfach aus höflichkeit gründen
ich konnte sache nicht mal mehr
verschenken also ich von meiner tochter
zum spielen geben
allein wenn ich mir schon diese serie
kolberg form angucken
die einfach sockeln ist das sind weiter
ohne ende drin und die form die wand
einfach nicht stoppen das heißt ja nicht
an teig einfüllen und den backe dann
läuft mit teig aus und gerade hier nicht
dass jetzt so vergleich mit dieser
plattform mit dieser silikon backfrauen
dies habe ich euch ja schon eine video
gezeigt von durch das ist einfach eine
richtig gute feste backform die gibt's
jetzt nicht oder bzw noch nicht in
meinem shop
da halte ich mich darum kümmern auf
jeden fall möchte hier nur ein paar
beispiele zeigen
von der struktur rolle dass also es geht
einfach gar nicht dass sie das in
spielzeug
es geht nicht darum ums aussehen oder so
soll es geht um die funktion
wenn ich mir anschaue wie meine struktur
rolle von steter aussieht das ist eine
handgemachte struktur rolle also allein
der unterschied dass hier ist richtig
holen
plastik und dass sich matti ist
handgefertigt
die ganzen einzelblüten handgemacht und
der einfache unterschied auch wenn ich
mit dieser rolle über meinen form gar
nicht rolle
dann sind die blumen eingedrückt wenn
ich mit dieser rolle über den vom land
rolle dann stechen die blumen außen
fondant hervor
also ich möchte nicht eine tor zu machen
wo die blumen dann eingedrückt sind
sondern eine idee die blumen um draußen
also nur so als beispiel
und das ist das paradebeispiel also
dieser ausstecher mit dieser aus live
funktion
normalerweise sollte ausstecher so
funktionieren dass man ihn hält
den teig oder den fondant aussticht und
dann etwas rüttelt und daneben prägt
aber das geht bei dem einfach gar nicht
weil das einfach diese funktion nicht
habe das ist wieder zurück schießt ich
zeige mich einfach mal was ich meinen
sind hier das sich dann ernst ausstechen
dann drücke und deswegen springt immer
wieder zurück und dann kann ich denn die
oder die von dann oder blüten und paste
rauswerfen
wie ihr seht ist für mich qualität des a
und o und qualität heißt für mich nicht
dass die preise überteuert sind qualität
heißt für mich dass die produkte stimmen
aber auch dass das
preis-leistungs-verhältnis stimmt und
ich finde gerade bei diesen produkten
stimmt das preis leistungs verhältnis
mir bringt einfach nichts wenn später
irgendjemand kommt was beim ihren shop
bestellt und dann diese sachen alle
wieder zurück kommen und ich dann sag du
aber was erwartest du denn für zwei euro
also von daher muss das alles stimmen
und da stehe ich auch dafür unter stehe
ich auch wirklich zu 100 prozent
dahinter und wollte ich jetzt einfach
mit diesem video mal zeigen wie eben
mein job zutrauen bekamen wie die
produkte zustande kamen
das eben ich mein produkt repertoire
auch noch erweitern werde aber das eben
jetzt mit der zeit geschieht weil ich
einfach mit meiner zeit natürlich auch
umgehen muss ihr richtig gelernt ich bin
mutter ich bin hausbau und alles
zusammen
da kann ich übrigens auf den nächsten
punkt ansprechen und jetzt eben noch zu
den vielen fragen die mich immer
erreichen über e-mail über facebook über
youtube über instagram über und jetzt
eben auch über diese neue schaltfläche
im onlineshop über die sekunden über
dieses kontaktformular
ich bitte euch darum dass so ein
bisschen voneinander zu trennen
und zwar die fragen bezüglich torten und
so weiter könnt ihr mir bei facebook
oder bei youtube direkt unter kommentar
stellen und am besten noch öffnen
damit einfach alle anderen auch was
davon haben und das kontaktformular im
shop biete nur für produkte des shops
verwenden also mit salz frage kommen
ebenso fachfragen zu torten und so
weiter dann werden die auch nicht
beantwortet weil es einfach so eine
vielzahl an fragen und e mails ist muss
überall nach e-mails und kommentaren
gucken und versuche es immer alles zu
beantworten und muss dann aber eben
einen fokus auf fragen legen die eben
auch richtig an dem richtigen
ausgestellt wurden
bei mission dem ich auch so dass ich die
fragen selbst beantworten möchte und
nicht irgend jemanden beauftragen
ich habe jetzt zwar schon aber zu meinen
ehemann beauftragt dass er mal das
beantwortet ich eben das durchs telefon
diktiert aber das könnt ihr ganz schnell
erkennen weil da die große scheibe und
die rechtschreibung einfach nicht so
perfekt ist und das ist dann trotzdem
das was ich sage aber ich muss es
einfach auch um zu machen weiß auch gar
nicht mehr hinterherkommen und ich eben
mich erst abends an den laptop setzte
und das von meinem handy aus nicht so
gut geht deswegen bitte ich euch ja
wirklich nur darum bei facebook vor
allen dingen ist es ganz toll weil da
auch viele zuschauer sind dies auch
kommentieren die dann die fragen schon
beantworten wenn ich noch nicht online
werden da ist zum beispiel die nicole
von nicoles backwerk oder die von der
familie zucker stube oder die dunja von
sugar creation zwei dunja oder die setup
oder tina kaiser oder die bildschirm
das sind einfach alles ganz treue
abonnenten die einfach schon für mich
sprechen und die frage beantworten ich
finde es wirklich richtig süß und freu
mich da immer drüber und finde es ganz
klar weil ich so im gegenseitig
unterstützt ich sage ein stück weit
entlastet kann mich um andere dinge
kümmern und dass wenn sich eben ganz gut
wie nicht einhalten würden und sei damit
auch echt nicht enttäuscht wenn da eben
beim kontakt vorbereiten shop keine
fragen da diesbezüglich eben beantwortet
werden
jetzt möchte ich das video gar nicht
weiter erweitern
haben ganz kurzen tipp für euch und zwar
wegen der kitchenaid weil sie einfacher
e mails eintreffen wurden stets ich
möchte mir die kitchenaid kaufen
aber ich muss meine man noch davon
überzeugen und jetzt ich mir dazu
eingefallen
das müsste einfach ganz geschickt machen
und zwar trotz was hat eine bohrmaschine
gekostet möchte wie ist die hitze hilft
ihm zu hilfe
außerdem passt führen also viel hat die
beständige kostet und die kann was macht
sie born und das kann sie noch ja die
condor born und die kids schon ex die
kann alles die kann packen die kleinen
bakken nicht anrühren
die kameras blicken die kann einfach
alles das wisst ihr ja um mit dem
argument müsste eben kommt die toile
baumaschinen vom ehemann kann in bonn
und die kitchenaid kann eben alles
andere vorhanden lohnt sich die
anschaffung und gerade jetzt ein guter
zeitpunkt kurz vor weihnachten die
kitchenaid kann auch boni aber das
braucht
und jetzt wünsche ich euch noch einen
ganz schönen tag mit einem neuen video